now made on your slide tonight more than
60 percent of us plan to give a gift
card this year what most people don't
realize however is you can actually save
money on gift card purchases tonight
with the help from our consumer savings
expert we take a look at the eight gift
card saving tax
snag a discount gift card at sites like
raise card cash and gift card granny
they sell other people's unwanted gift
cards at up to 25 off secondly earn cash
back on your gift card purchase a
cashback site like couponcabin.com gives
you cash back for a variety of retail
sites so just click through the site to
get cash back for your gift card
purchase you can get 4.5 percent back at
Macy's three percent back at Sephora and
up to four percent back at Walmart
consumer saving expert Andrea Warrick
says the third tip is to look for free
gift cards with purchase this week at
Metro Pizza you get a 10 gift card when
you buy a 25 one there are also offers
at Massage Envy and then that free 20
dollar promo card you got would be a
great gift for a friend co-worker or
maybe a teacher a babysitter in your
life buy your gift card from a warehouse
store Costco and Sam's Club offer
multi-packs of gift cards for 20 to 30
savings redeem rewards review your
credit card for points or miles that can
be redeemed for gift cards and check
store loyalty programs using cash back
apps like fetch rewards will also earn
you points toward free gift cards to a
variety of retailers and restaurants
check your credit card for exclusive
savings and the seventh tip browse daily
deal sites like Groupon at LivingSocial
the eighth tip ask for a gift card
behind the service desk or grab the last
one in the group behind the display to
cut down on the chances that the card
has been hacked